it took decades but fans of the 1982
cult hit Tron finally got a sequel with
Tron Legacy in 2010
not long after Disney announced a third
movie codenamed Tron ascension was in
the works
then nothing and the studio reportedly
pulled the plug in 2015 at this point it
seems Disney might be waiting another
three decades before considering its
next Tron movie here's a look at why
there won't be another light cycle trip
around the grid anytime soon box-office
dud Tron Legacy earned 400 million
dollars worldwide on a hundred and
seventy million dollar budget and while
that's a lot of money for the sequel to
a 30 year old cult hit it still wasn't
quite enough to launch a franchise for
the sake of perspective Disney's
live-action Alice in Wonderland was
released in the same year as Tron Legacy
and it brought in more than a billion
dollars at the box office
four hundred million dollars might sound
like a lot but Disney is used to making
a lot more not disney enough when the
Tron sequel was axed in 2015
Disney's release calendar was already
booked pretty solid with tentpole
releases like Cinderella The Jungle Book
Beauty and the Beast and yes another
Alice in Wonderland what's the common
theme here outside of the Marvel movies
Disney's live-action slate is almost
exclusively remakes of its animated hits
Disney knows what works and going with a
proven story that fans already loved is
far less risky than rolling the dice on
another Tron unless of course they can
find a way to shoehorn Iron Man into
their Tomorrowland bombed Disney pulled
the plug on a third Tron movie in May
2015
almost immediately after Tomorrowland
tanked at the box office like Tron
Tomorrowland was an ambitious sci-fi
film with a family-friendly angle and
like Tron it didn't do all that well
despite having George Clooney star and
Brad Bird in the director's chair
Tomorrowland couldn't clear 100 million
dollars at the u.s. box office falling
well below its reported 200 million
dollar budget
fresh off Tron legacies lackluster
performance Tomorrowland was
confirmation that audiences just aren't
interest
enough in this type of movie took too
long the plot of the third Tron was
reportedly gonna follow Olivia Wilde's
Cora as she ventures out into the real
world
wild coasts are Garrett Hedlund and
director Joseph Kosinski were all set to
return but when filming was about to
start in late 2015
Disney shelved the project at that point
original star bruce boxleitner said he
was no longer interested in making
another Tron after seeing how Disney was
treating the franchise I'm done with it
I've moved on I hate to say that but
it's been - up and down for me and if
they did move forward now it'd be pretty
hard to make a Tron movie without Tron
Tron uprising crashed in 2012 Disney XD
launched the animated series Tron
uprising to tie into the world of Tron
Legacy and potentially set up a new
live-action sequel the show is actually
pretty good but after launching with
nearly 2 million viewers the ratings
took a nosedive to around 300,000 by the
time the first season wrapped if Disney
was looking to the series as a proving
ground that fans wanted more Tron it
pretty much proved the opposite toy
troubles Disney makes a lot of movies
and it also sells a whole lot of toys a
lot of tie in merchandise was launched
alongside Tron Legacy in 2010 but the
toys and games were never really big
sellers which closed off a potentially
huge financial Avenue for Disney and its
partners the Tron evolution video game
which served as a prequel to Tron Legacy
sold a mere 190,000 copies which is
pretty terrible for a hyped game built
around what should have been a hot
property waiting game the time might not
be right for a neutron sequel now but
what's old will be new again eventually
right franchises like these tend to come
back around after a while in Hollywood
and it stands to reason Tron will be no
exception if it ever does it sounds like
at least they have a great script ready
to go between us so if it took 30 years
for Tron Legacy to get made we can go
ahead and pencil in a day at around 2040
for the next one right thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this other cool stuff we
know you
to
[Music]